let's talk about the following let's
talk about consequences
okay
because the average person's watching
this you made a great point
bitcoin is up you know ethereum is up
i'm talking crypto then you talk about
the stock market everything is up
treasury's up
america looks strong today america
looked pretty good today america looked
like they stood up to the bully today
that's a good thing for him to stand up
and stand up to the bully today and by
the way you can watch the old press
conference with the briefing with the
president today go watch the questions
at the end the whole thing is like 25
minutes but watch the last seven minutes
eight minutes that's the main part if
you don't have 25 minutes to watch the
whole thing i recommend everybody to go
watch the seven minutes on going back
and forth there's a couple parts that
you may want to catch
is the following question consequences
number one um
so
what do sanctions do
because everything's got a side effect
if i eat a lot of cheesecake there's a
side effect
if i drink too much red bull there's a
if i gamble my money there's a side
effect
if i fight with my spouse and i you know
belittle them all the time there's a
side effect there's side effects to
everything right okay
what is the side effect
to
putting sanction on russia the way that
you didn't you cost 45
okay um
when we put sanctions on china
they look good for a month
they look good for two months
they look good for six months
it look good for 12 months
months of constant consecutive expanse
of monsa
and then puff out of nowhere this thing
showed up called kobe
now
not telling you it's bio warfare
conversation
but you push the bear kobe popped out
and it kind of ruined the whole world
for about 18 months threw everybody off
it was a mess and we're barely coming
off of this thing here right now with
masks kids going to school all this
stuff barely and we're not even there
yet with many of the states right
we live in florida we know florida we're
not even in effect you don't even feel
it but the rest of the country illinois
michigan new york jersey california
so
what is russia's specialty
is it nuclear war because they got a lot
of nuclear weapons i think they're
number two behind us
would he pull that one off
i don't know has that been russia's
specialty or is russia going to play the
proxy game
and what is the proxy game
is it going to be a different strength
that they have one of the strengths
russia has is cyber warfare
russia is very good at cyber listen many
of us know the effects of a bio warfare
if it was a bio warfare which we don't
know if it was a bio warfare the
investigation hasn't yet been done but i
think the tribunal world needs to
investigate and find out what happened i
don't know you don't know nobody knows
the government doesn't know we haven't
done the proper investigation yet we
don't would like to find out what
happened there we haven't gone and done
the proper audits etc etc
but do we know what happens if we go
through cyber warfare
has anybody ever had their passwords
taken from them
you ever had your instagram profile
where you get an email saying you're
about to get verified you fill out that
information you put your password boom
somebody takes your account over and
asks you for five thousand dollars or a
bitcoin to get your instagram back has
that ever happened to you you ever
gotten a call from american express
talking about the fact that hey let me
tell you somebody's doing fraudulent
activities we put a freeze and you get
that call from one eight hundred two two
four and you know it's amax you ever had
those kind of calls you ever had a call
like that and what does it do to your
day you ever had your you know social
security you ever had somebody take your
stuff and go get a bunch of credit cards
and spend a bunch of money you ever had
that happen before how much of a pain in
the ass is it never had to go recover
and go get a second social or change
your social because things got pretty
bad we don't know the effects of a cyber
warfare folks we don't know it
and putin's not a guy
that
david
don't move on
hey you know i believe in god and god
asked me to forgive and i gotta move on
putin doesn't come across as the guy
that's gonna go and say heavenly father
shall i forgive president biden for
putting all the sanctions on my people
and publicly humiliating me and he got
in the way of me getting ukraine back
which is part of our motherland and
that's one of our family members but he
got in the way and i'm determined and
convinced that was supposed to happen
and
i ask you for forgiveness in advance for
what i may do to u.s and america
none of us know
so we don't know what's going to happen
with the consequences we don't the best
thing that we know is the following
here's the best thing that we know
is that nato is unified
eu for the most part is unified
and america
is not too happy
about what he's doing but the only
people that are not we've heard nothing
from china
nothing why
i don't know
so if those two guys are on the same
team and the rest of the world says well
who cares what they want to do let them
be on the same team
they're not too lightweights you know
how in sports like allowing shaq and
kobe to get on the same team yeah it's
going to be three championships you
can't let
a powerhouse like russia and a
powerhouse like china to team up you
ain't just letting the two of the most
powerful players in the league get on
the same team let's just say chicago has
michael but lakers have kobe and shaq
that's kind of what's going on today so
there are some things that i hope our uh
government our president our military
leaders are having these types of
conversations behind closed doors and
i'm sure they are i'm sure they're way
ahead of the game we have a very strong
middle
and
for the most part
i love this street i want to
uh not willing to selling their souls
souls out to another country like that
but we have to pay very close attention
and not be naive about the fact that
putin's not going to sit there and allow
somebody to publicly humiliate him i'm
convinced that's not his character
[Music]